[Applause]
young beautiful people there's nothing
like it so it's take our beautiful
children to work sons and daughters and
it's a great honor to have to have you
at the White House you've made tours
you've been with the Secret Service
you've been with some of the great
people including your parents right are
your parents great people I think so if
they're not we have a major story right
we have a big story but I want to
welcome all of the young people great
people the future it's the future
to the White House it's a very special
day and it's officially called take our
daughters and our sons to work day right
that's the politically correct term and
we always have to be politically correct
right so that's good I know your parents
are very proud of you they're very very
proud indeed and a lot of the parents
are here most of them are here and I see
Sarah your beautiful kids and so many
they work the media I even love the
media today I see these beautiful
children products of the media and I
actually like you much more than your
parents but this afternoon you've had an
exciting chance to look behind the
scenes at the White House and to see to
the critical work that your mom's and
your dad's do each year and that is the
people that work here and the people
that cover it and that's the press and
just incredible job they do they work
very very hard day and night and that's
what they think about our country is
doing very well I will tell you our
economy is at a level that perhaps it's
never been at and all over the world
they're talking about our great country
and how well we're doing I understand
that you've seen my presidential
limousine that's called the Beast I
guess it's one of the world's most
expensive cars unfortunately it's like
riding in an army tank you have the same
kind of protect
but it's something very special you've
met some of our really great heroes and
you've even met our wonderful service
dog so our service dogs are incredible
you know with the finest equipment in
the world drug detection equipment and
while I have you never take drugs don't
drink alcohol
don't smoke enjoy your life okay no
drugs no alcohol no smoke all right you
don't need it you don't need it because
there's a lot of problems so just
remember that if you learned one thing I
didn't come up here to say that but I
will say it I say it all the time to my
kids I've said it from the time Ivanka
was a little girl every day I'd say
Ivanka no drugs no alcohol no smoking
nothing and she'd say dad enough already
I'd save so much I'd say it so much so
I'm saying it to you because I mean it
and I think your parents mean it I know
your parents made it you become Junior
Rangers with the National Park Service
which was exciting and that makes the
White House really incredible because
they make the White House so incredible
and you visited with our terrific
presidential photographers very talented
people you take pictures you've seen
people from all over the world some of
the great pictures that they get very
talented talented people I wish they
could make me look just a little bit
better sometimes I think they do it on
purpose actually they give me pictures
always my chin is pulled way in I look
terrible but that's okay they do that a
purpose and this afternoon usual you've
all written letters of thank you to the
brave warriors of our United States
military for defending our American flag
very special people on behalf of the
first lady of myself and she was with
you for a large part of the day we hope
that you've had a terrific time
some of you were here last year and I
remember a couple of you and you've
grown a lot bigger it's been twelve
months but you've grown a lot bigger as
you've seen the White House is the
special place a very special place of
our nation you look back and you see so
many other things Jefferson Memorial you
see the Washington Monument it's really
incredible sometimes I walk up these
paths and I look around and I say wow
there is no place like this anywhere on
earth anywhere no matter where you go
there is no place like right here you
have beautiful homes you're beautiful
everything but there's just no place
like this the White House is a place of
history 1799 that's a long time now when
President Xi comes from China and I say
1799 he thinks that's a modern house
because their culture is very very old
five thousand years but this is really
something that no matter where you go no
matter the time no matter the date there
is nothing like our great White House
your moms and dads are working very hard
to keep our country safe from danger and
to keep America prosperous thriving and
strong they're fighting for better
health care and better schools to help
millions of other families just like
yours and they're making sure that the
White House puts its best foot forward
when we welcome foreign leaders on
American soil we have Prime Minister
Abbey of Japan coming tomorrow it'll be
a very important meeting we will soon be
having President Xi from China coming we
have many many of their leaders
ultimately all of the great leaders come
here they are reporting your parents on
our country and that's the White House
press corps they report they let you
know how we're doing and often times
they report correctly actually most of
the time your parents all the time right
all the time
most of the time what do you alright all
the time see I agree for purposes of
this speech I agree but they are and
they are protecting all of your families
and they're getting the word out and
they want to get the word out fairly and
honestly your parents are serving our
entire nation and I'm sure you will
agree with me that they're doing it to
make a better future for you it's all
about you sort of no longer about us
it's about you they work so hard for you
and our country works so hard for you
for the rest of your life you will be
proud to say my mom or my dad worked at
the White House it's a very big thing so
I want to do this I'm gonna ask you most
of your parents are with you I'm gonna
ask you to look around grab your parents
give them big applause and give them all
a big fat kiss right now so cute
[Applause]
right
I'm not nice be proud of them and I'm
proud of them too
I really am I also want to say a special
thanks to each of you because it's your
smiles and love of your parents after a
long day's work that helps make
everything here possible it's what
really makes them come back and back and
back and at what really makes them do a
very special job the job they do so I
want to thank you for supporting your
mom's and your dad's they are special
people do we agree they're special say I
love you mom and dad that's true to
every young person here today thank you
again for coming to the White House now
I want to take a good look around
because if you keep learning you keep
trying and you keep dreaming one day you
might be standing exactly right here
where I'm standing I won't tell you it's
not that easy it's not easy but it's
really something very special we're
doing a special job and you're doing a
special job and your parents are very
incredible people so I want to thank
them for being here I want to thank them
for bringing you we'll see you again
next year you'll be a little bit bigger
and a lot wiser and go to school and
learn and work hard do the best you can
and remember what I said no drugs no
alcohol you'll lead a great life no
smoking no smoking and just have a great
great life and congratulations to you
and your incredible parents thank you
for being here appreciate it thank you
[Applause]